[Aplausos]
yo soy miriam una persona curiosa que
siempre quiere andar lo tocando todo y
saber por qué suceden las cosas porque
vas diferente vestido diferente a mí
porque hablan un idioma que yo no
entiendo qué es lo que los hace ser
diferentes a mí
este son el tipo de preguntas que yo
suelo hacer cuando llevo a un nuevo
lugar y es que después de viajar por un
año me ha dado cuenta que viajar es más
interesante desde que se dore cuando se
integran a la sociedad de la zona a la
que llegan esto porque bueno porque van
a descubrir que no hay una sola verdad y
que aparte no hay una sola realidad sino
que hay muchísimas y tal vez se pregunte
esta chica de dónde ha sacado que hay un
montón de realidades pues si las hay
verán ella es su pasar a la conocida del
norte de tailandia cuando se acercó al
lado de a mí le sorprendió que
estuviéramos en este lugar tan alejado
del turismo ella trabaja para una
asociación que ayuda a la reinserción
social de mujeres que han sido
secuestradas de sus hogares para la
prostitución
pero esto qué tiene que ver con lo que
acabo de decirles de que viajar te ayuda
a ver que hay muchas realidades pues
verán en tailandia hay una práctica muy
de moda entre los turistas que es hacer
turismo sexual no tengo que contarles en
qué consiste porque se lo pueden
imaginar
pues bien la asociación de esta chica
ayuda a mujeres que han sido víctimas de
trata de blancas las mismas víctimas que
han sido explotadas en barrios como los
que frecuentan muchos de estos turistas
se estima que alrededor de 300.000
mujeres están en esta situación
y que los ingresos que aporta esta
actividad
son de 4500 millones de dólares
y tal vez estos hombres no se estaban
dando cuenta de lo que había detrás de
esta actividad ellos sólo estaban viendo
una cara de la realidad verdad por eso
digo que en el mundo no hay una verdad
absoluta que defina realmente cómo son
las cosas lo que para ustedes puede ser
negro para ellos puede ser blanco y la
única manera de ver cómo es que para
nosotros es de un color diferente
tenemos que darles la oportunidad de que
nos los expliquen
y tal vez ustedes piensen a mí en la
vida se me ocurriría hacer turismo
sexual
ok no seamos tan tan drásticos vayamos a
otra actividad que seguramente hacemos
mucho durante nuestros viajes que es
sacar fotografías por favor alcen la
mano a aquellas personas que suelen
sacar fotografías durante sus viajes
pueden bajarla por favor ya yo también
me incluyo porque me gusta tener un
recuerdo de mis viajes pues qué pasaría
si yo les dijera que hacer fotografías
puede tener un impacto negativo en las
personas locales me creería
hagamos una cosa imaginen que ustedes
están comiendo con sus amigos están
jugando con sus hijos no se cenando con
su pareja y de repente llega un extraño
y les empieza a sacar fotografías sin
más sin preguntarles nada
que sentirían
ahora imagínense no uno ni dos y mucho
menos tres decenas de turistas sacando
las fotografías día tras día día tras
día
suena un poco agobiante verdad
pues esta es la realidad que viven
muchos locales cuando los turistas van y
les sacan fotografías porque piensan que
son personas exóticas curiosas y una
actividad que en un principio era
inocente se convierte en una actividad
con un impacto negativo
pero entonces que hacemos y dejamos de
sacar fotografías en nuestros viajes no
estándar la respuesta la respuesta está
en la forma en la que lo hacemos esta
fotografía que ustedes ven aquí es del
festival del año nuevo acá los acá son
una etnia al norte de tailandia y en
este evento ellos festejan la edad nueva
temporada de lluvias esperan que les dé
buenas cosechas esta fotografía como
esta y muchas otras se hicieron con el
permiso de los locales no hubo necesidad
de que yo llegara con mi cámara y los
bombardeadas con el flash así pam pam
pam y de hacerlos sentir incómodos lo
pueden ver ellos mismos pasaban
pero como le hice para poder acercarme a
ellos pues la verdad es que fue bastante
fácil yo todos los días me la pasaba
desayunando comiendo y cenando en el
mismo local de esta señora que
participaba en el festival yo pasaba
tanto tiempo en su local que ya se
aparecía un elemento más de decoración
ahí
entonces precisamente fue a través de
esta persona que yo tuve la oportunidad
de ver este evento
que de no haber sido por haber convivido
con ella no hubiera tenido la
oportunidad
y es con este tipo de experiencias que
uno se da cuenta lo que se lo que se
pierde metido en un hotel en un hostal
sin salir a conocer a los locales porque
les aseguro que las mejores experiencias
las pase en compañía de esta gente aún
recuerdo hay un entrega de la playera
blanca él me acogió en su casa cuando
fui a japón daba la casualidad de que en
esos días era mi cumpleaños y en un día
no organizó una fiesta montó una
barbacoa y en medio de su sala invitó a
otros viajeros que tampoco conocía y se
puso a hacer un pastel en una arrocera
hizo que era la primera vez que hace un
pastel
yo me quedé sorprendida de cómo es que
un extraño que me acaba de conocer que
me acaba de abrir las puertas de su casa
se preocupa por tener ese detalle
conmigo
y qué puedo decir de de keita
este chico que también me abrió las
puertas de su casa me llevó a recorrer
la zona más rural de japón y fuimos a un
festival en donde tuve la oportunidad de
ver cómo se hace una catana a la manera
tradicional
y no sólo eso también organizó un
intercambio con una chef bastante famosa
donde me enseñaba a cocinar comida
japonesa y yo le enseñaría a hacer
comida mexicana esta experiencia fue un
poco peculiar porque tuve que usar los
chips de estos palitos que usualmente se
utilizan en muchos países asiáticos y
claro era algo diferente para mí porque
en occidente no los utilizamos para
cocinar
entonces es cuando a mí me medio algo en
la cabeza o algo me pensé algo que a
veces encontrarnos con otros puntos de
vista diferentes a los nuestros nos hace
replantearnos nuestra vida
que si lo que veníamos haciendo era la
mejor forma de hacerlo
que si dan lo mejor hay otros caminos
que nos pueden llevar a nuestras metas
si no los conocíamos o si simplemente
éramos más afortunados que otros y no
sabíamos valorarlo
esto último me pasó cuando conocí a john
yo es una niña vietnamita de unos 10
años que todas las tardes sale a vender
pulseras a veces lo hace con sus con sus
amigos
y una niña que está a la izquierda
siempre va cargando sobre su espalda un
bebé
es una situación bastante fuerte pero es
precisamente cuando se convive con estas
personas que nos ponemos en sus zapatos
algo bastante difícil pero no imposible
entonces yo yo los invito a que ustedes
salgan de la zona de confort turística
no importa si no hablan el mismo idioma
de estas personas y si existe un
traductor en su celular que les puede
facilitar la vida también se pueden
comunicar las señas o como ustedes
quieran lo importante es querer aprender
igualmente hay aplicaciones que te
ayudan a pedir alojamiento en casa de
los locales y ustedes mismos pueden
fungir como anfitriones y recibir a
otros viajeros y lo mejor de todo es que
no va a costar ni un solo euro lo único
que tienen que hacer es que voy a tener
que recibir estas personas como si fuera
un miembro más de su familia un amigo
siempre hay que informarnos bien de los
lugares a los que vamos no hay que ir en
cero porque les aseguro que esto puede
marcar la diferencia entre que ellos nos
reciban con los brazos abiertos o
quieran que marchemos
no nos tenemos que ir a lo mejor tan
lejos para que entiendan todo esto que
les estoy diciendo recuerden a los
turistas que han venido aquí a sus
hogares
que ha hecho que disfrutaran de su
compañía o que quieran que se marchen y
no vuelvan a ser lo mismo cuando
nosotros viajamos estamos yendo a la
casa de esas personas
esto del aprendizaje mientras viajas
tienen que visualizarlo como si fueran
un vaso de agua
el agua representa todas las
experiencias que ustedes han vivido a lo
largo de su vida
pero cuando viajan deben vaciar ese vaso
y permitir que nuevas experiencias
entren no siempre van a estar de acuerdo
con lo que con lo que encuentren pero al
menos tienen que estar abiertos a la
posibilidad de conocerlo
hace poco un sociólogo decía que habría
que ser menos turistas y más viajeros
y tenía razón porque viajar debe servir
para conocer no solamente para mostrar y
para posar porque les aseguro que
después de viajar integrándose a la
sociedad de la zona a la que llegan
les va a ayudar a que antes de juzgar a
otros por no pensar como ustedes lo
hacen se preguntarán por qué lo está
haciendo porque actúa de esa forma y
sobre todo porque yo actuó de esta
manera gracias
[Aplausos]